situation here is just intensifying not
only tonight
but day one day this is the 11th night
of tear gas
being fired at protesters here and the
number of people taking the streets is
just growing
what i can tell you now is a crowd of
protesters here
who are throwing things over this
temporary fence which has been put up to
protect the federal courthouse
now they're throwing things over at
federal troops who
are here they say to protect federal
properties
they've been throwing fireworks into the
federal courthouse
federal troops as you can hear our
federal troops have been firing tear gas
back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
between federal agents and themselves
and they don't seem to be going anywhere
anytime soon
now it's not just protesters who've been
injured
members of the federal force have also
been injured as well
and in fact we've seen some of them have
had green lasers shot into their eyes
tonight and we understand that some of
them have suffered
eye injuries because of that these
protesters
do seem to have a very coordinated
process carrying out these protests at
the moment they know what they're doing
and they do not seem to be deterred by
the tear gas
and by the rubber bullets which are
being fired at them now
now as you can see
[Applause]
as you can see this fence which has been
put up around the federal courthouse to
protect it
and of course to protect the federal
troops now for regarding it
it's being pushed down by protesters and
you might be able to make out but it's
bending inwards here
now this is of great concern
because if if that fence goes
there could be a very real threat to
life here
because the number of protesters by far
outnumber the number of federal offices
here
now these federal troops were sent in
around three weeks
ago after the fourth of july holiday
after weeks and weeks of on the whole
peaceful protests in support of black
lives matter
and the presence of these troops here in
portland has
only angered people it's brought more
people onto the street
the mayor of portland says they're not
welcome the governor of oregon said
they're not welcome
but they are not leaving and these
protesters
are not going anywhere either it feels
very
it feels very much chicken and egg here
one is not going while the other is
still here
it's hard it's hard to see
how this is going to end but it doesn't
feel like it's going to end well